what i would do is continue doing what
you're doing but set
earmark
10
20
and invest the hell out of that whether
that's in
real estate whether that's in the stock
market mutual funds index funds whether
that's in crypto whatever it is
and start to build your wealth because
you never know what will happen [ __ ]
does happen and if you're making this
much money you never want to say bro i
was making 20 million dollars a year and
now i'm broke i don't know what happened
take a couple million bucks each year
put that aside get rental property
whatever you want to do
do that and then you can take
if you can't live on 80 to make these
videos then i don't know what to tell
you okay don't forget the tithing sauce
praise jesus
thank you paul uh did we we were gonna
cut paul's mic right
um
anyway i would uh
i would tell mr beast keep doing what
you're doing people love your videos
respect to you just make sure that
you're saving that money yeah and using
some of that as an investment his time
is on his side he's 23 years old this
guy if he plays his cards right this guy
could have 100 million bucks by the time
he's 40 years old yeah and never have to
actually worry about
um
or go and check to check or let me get
dark on you real quick yes or
he you know he makes all this money he's
constantly reinvesting it in the videos
the next thing you know he runs out of
ideas mr beast hits a wall he's run out
of hoops to jump through he doesn't know
what to do and he's sitting on a bunch
of x-boxes and you know a bunch of
basketballs that are zero gravity who
knows what he's messing with nowadays
i say i say mr beast i've seen you do a
lot of crazy stuff i'm a fan i see the
numbers you're doing
save that money mr beast wow say that i
couldn't have said that better myself
i couldn't have so with that being said
let's move on to the next topic
here is our second
wild money move of the week this is the
quick story right here but it's
basically there's nobody out there
that's going to identify with the story
i'm telling you up front you're not
going to identify with this story right
i know
multi-multi-millionaire are gonna say i
have no clue how to even function or
even fathom what they're talking about
in this story this home is so expensive
it's so expensive marcelo that nobody
wants it that's it nobody wants it
nobody wants this ridiculous house
so here it is the most expensive home in
america defaults on
165
million dollars in debt and it heads for
sale so let me read this story to you
and you tell me if this is something
that you would even want in your life
this is such a ridiculous house that i
think it's it's
too much to chew
too you know they say don't eat an
elephant in one bite right this house is
such a big bite i don't know if you were
willing to take a big bite out of it
amen what if what if mr beast buys this
house
that would be sick i like what you did
there so this los angeles this la mega
mansion paul's favorite state la mega
mansion once expected the list for 500
million dollars has gone into
receivership after the owner defaulted
on more than 165 million dollars in
loans and in debt this is according to
court
filings the 105 000 square foot bel air
estate known as
the one
now
known as
the one that got away
uh is expected to be listed at a lower
price yeah it's flashy developer niall
nayami touted the property as his life
mission as the biggest most expensive
home in the urban world so this home
was expected to hit the market in 2017
with a price tag of 500 million million
and the one aka the one that got away
has been dogged by repeated delays
funding problems and changing strategies
now let me tell you how freaking
expansive expensive and extensive this
home i didn't think i'd have three x
words right there he's dead you killed
it and i just went there let me tell you
how big this home is this ultra-modern
palace
was over eight acres on a hilltop
overlooking la it has nine bedrooms
which seems a little it seems like nice
yeah seems a little light
nine bedrooms multiple kitchens right a
nightclub in the house
a bowling alley a salon a gym
a 50-seat movie theater a running track
and an underground garage for
not one
not five not ten
fifty different cars you must be a car
lover if you love this place and it has
two auto turntables you know like these
turntables that you can
not a dj
like where you park your cars and they
turn around like you ever seen these
things like carvana have you ever seen
that yeah
going on it has
seven
water fountains including multiple pools
jacuzzi and a freaking moat like he's a
castle with king henry viii and a moat
that surrounds the house and get this
here's the the thing that is just like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
the master bedroom
just the master bedroom is 4 000 square
feet that is the size
of a house
the master bedroom is a house and all in
itself
we have pictures of this thing yeah this
is the uh so this is apparently like the
outside of it it's like a modern
home
um that's the outside it looks
and then this is the aerial view which
is pretty insane
oh
so it's like that's the okay gotcha on
the hill that is overlooking la crazy
huh let's kill that anyway turn that off
um
can we turn that off what kill the
article there's audio going on right now
oh you can hear that yeah
um anyways all right it sounds better
now okay yeah i forgot you can't hear
what's going on i can't hear anything
it's the most annoying commercial in the
world i'm like we killed that
sorry guys
um
anyway it looks like a college campus
over there okay
here's
here's the problem here what's my
takeaway with all this you know how they
say the bigger the house what's your
point sausage this is the pbd line
we've been waiting we've been waiting
what's your point
sometimes they say the bigger the house
the bigger the headaches sometimes they
say mo money mo problems
this guy had the most problems and the
most headaches of any house in the
history of the world right here he
thought he was going to sell it for 500
million and he can't even get 165
million for it right now
um
it's kind of insane marcelo i know you
wanted to use some analogy it's kind of
like dating a girl whatever yeah this is
it seems to me like a um you know a hot
girl that's got a lot of baggage you
know like it looks beautiful from the
outside
but
once you get into you know the brick and
mortar and what's behind the big french
doors
you notice that this is actually more
problems than benefits yes um i imagine
it's a beautiful home i imagine walking
through this place is a dream
but
i don't think anyone would take
the like if i bought this house my first
thought would be
oh no
i just bought this house yeah it would
be a big problem so
yeah it's a it's a scary commitment to
make i mean i i don't have
i don't have i don't have a hundred
dollars to spend on a house let alone
500 million dollars to spend on the
house yeah well i think it's a good sign
that nobody if there was some bidding
war going on i'll give you 500. 510 550.
600 like that's like what
i think people's minds would be blown
yeah the fact that the most expensive
house
ever
is not being sold i think people are
like all right it's a good thing things
aren't that freaking insane right it
shows some financial literacy my two
bedroom apartment that i rent for 2 000
bucks is gonna suit me just fine yes
what's wrong with renting how much would
it be to rent this house you think jesus
okay so that's good to know that this
500 million market i wish this house
well
uh i i would love to party there
um right
i would love to bowl there i'd love to
swim in one of its pools there i would
not not like to keep up with the
maintenance yeah the maintenance every
year i would guess is probably
disgusting a million bucks on
maintenance disgusting it's insane
anyway owning a house like that ain't
all that it's cracked up to be saved
that money good job to anybody that has
a lot of money that didn't like good job
to mr beast because mr b says it makes a
lot of money yeah good job to him to
most of these guys like all these
billionaires like jeff bezos jeff bezos
was dr was making like 20 billion
dollars driving a honda civic you know
like this is not where you want to live
if you have a real rich person
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken